good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
things are moving fast in american
politics but see if you can remember
back
five months to last fall at the time
elizabeth warren of massachusetts was
the most likely democratic nominee
she had big leads in both iowa and new
hampshire she'd overtaken establishment
designated front-runner joe biden
in the national polling the race last
fall
was warrens to lose and lose it she did
spectacularly
warren didn't win a single state in fact
she never took second
she got creamed in massachusetts where
she lives today
finally warren dropped out having
succeeded only in humiliating herself
as the babylon bee put it quote warren
returns to tribe in shame after failing
to take land back from the pale faces
you could imagine how disappointed the
cherokees were so what happened to
elizabeth warren
well it's interesting story actually
filled with valuable lessons for
political candidates as well as for the
rest of us
but warren was in no mood for learning
today she already knew the answer as
she so often does and it turned out to
be the very same answer she's offered in
response to virtually every question
she's been asked over the last six
months
it was sexism that's why she lost
democratic voters the majority of whom
are female hate women warren explained
they may have nominated a woman in the
last presidential race but that was
probably an act of sexism too
that's how sexist they are super duper
sexist
if you say yeah there was sexism in this
race
everyone says whiner and if you say no
there was no sexism
about a bazillion women think what
planet do you live on um
i promise you this i'll have a lot more
to say on that subject later on
that's a promise she said in other words
there will be many more lectures on
sexism to come from professor warren
buy your tickets now the hall is certain
to be packed in the front row you'll see
your favorite cable news commentators
who are themselves
lifelong warriors against sexism
yes it is true that these are the very
same people who have spent months now
acting as publicists for michael
bloomberg and now joe biden
both of whom are demonstrably male but
in their hearts our friends on tv were
always rooting for the woman that's the
kind of people they are
highly unsexist people our country is
still very uncomfortable
with women in power men come into a race
with the expectation that they're
qualified women have to prove themselves
when a woman takes a hit at particularly
a male candidate
she she takes a hit in her likability
senator warren
was hammered on her medicare for all
plan and her tax plans
in a way that none of the men were
exactly right the entire last year
to me that was a sexist double standard
she would
have done much better if she were a man
and i would like more
more men to be vocal about the fact that
they want to see
women in positions of leadership
yeah sexism she can see why elizabeth
warren is so upset tonight
to be fair bernie sanders did warn her
more than a year ago that a woman
couldn't win
he didn't want her to get hurt but she
just wouldn't
listen just kidding that never happened
warren made it up
or maybe she believed it happened which
is worse warner's convinced herself of a
lot of strange things recently it's been
poignant to watch it happen
warren is no beta o'rourke she isn't
doing bong hits on her skateboard after
lunch
she's a legitimately smart person
without question the smartest candidate
in the democratic field
she's also tough as hell and fake indian
affirmative action employee aside
she's fairly accomplished especially by
the low standards of political life
nearly 20 years ago warren wrote a book
called the two income trap about how the
mass
entry of mothers into the workforce left
families poorer
it was not a predictable academic
diatribe that ends with a call for
socialism
in fact it was interesting and well
researched and above all it was serious
one wrote about a real problem one that
affects most americans
and then thought deeply about how to
solve it the book was impressive
it could have been the basis of a
populist presidential campaign
that would have forced much-needed
national conversations about these
issues
and in the end might have won but none
of that ever happened
warren got derailed more precisely she
became infected with the virulent strain
of identity politics
by the end like tertiary syphilis it
drove her
insane one day warren was talking about
raising wages and protecting american
workers
the next she was ranting about strange
forms of racism nobody had ever heard of
and then attacking the country she has
once sought to improve
elizabeth warren went intersectional and
it killed her
here were some of the first symptoms in
a country now where the president
is advancing environmental racism
economic racism criminal justice racism
health care racism so raise your hand if
you ever heard of
health care racism raise both hands if
you think it's one of this country's top
500 problems elizabeth warren thought it
was
then she decided it was important in
fact our moral obligation
to invite the rest of the impoverished
world here to america to share
our job market and our health care
system how exactly would that help
american workers we're no longer cared
she was too woke to worry about
actual people by earlier this year she
clearly needed inpatient care
you watched her speeches hoping that men
with nets would spring from the shadows
to
carry her off to a secure facility
somewhere for a much-needed rest
unfortunately it never happened the
mania seemed to reach its peak in
january when warden suddenly announced
out of nowhere
that she would ask transgendered
children to pick her cabinet members
i'm going to have a secretary of
education
that this young trans person interviews
on my behalf and only if this person
believes
that our secretary or secretary of
education nominee
is someone who is committed to creating
a welcoming environment a safe
environment and a full
educational curriculum for everyone will
that person
actually be advanced to be secretary of
education
[Applause]
so who is this young trans person who
gets to staff the federal government
no one in the news media even asked
because it turns out warren wasn't the
only one who'd gone insane
all of this seemed perfectly normal to
cnn
but it wasn't normal it was shockingly
crazy almost hilariously crazy
but warren was not amused most of the
time she appeared to be flooredly
enraged
like she might lunge forward and bite
someone for reasons that were never
really clear
warren really hated bernie sanders the
elderly ex-mayor from vermont
at one point warren claimed that sanders
was in fact
a dangerous sexist but nobody believed
her it was just too implausible whatever
else he is
so she turned her wrath on michael
bloomberg a far richer target
i'd like to talk about who we're running
against a billionaire
who calls women fat broads and
horse-faced lesbians
and no i'm not talking about donald
trump i'm talking about mayor bloomberg
democrats are not going to win
if we have a nominee who has a history
of
hiding his tax returns of harassing
women
and of supporting racist policies
democrats take a huge risk
if we just substitute one arrogant
billionaire
for another got to give her credit she
could deliver a line
but by this stage in the campaign no one
outside cable news sets and college
campuses was listening
elizabeth warren kept talking but nobody
cared
why because it turns out that most
people even democrats
aren't that interested in intersectional
politics they don't know how to
pronounce the word
latin x and they don't want to learn
it's stupid
and weird and kind of threatening it is
precisely zero relevance to their lives
they want to hear politicians talk about
making the schools better or lowering
health insurance premiums the things
they actually think about at home
they don't want to hear some middle-aged
lady drone on in an extended guilt trip
because in the end it's really
all about her identity politics is
always
just a form of narcissism that's not
appealing to anybody
you can't get elected doing it elizabeth
warren just proved that conclusively
let's hope everyone else in politics
learns that lesson